The joe rogan experience.
Okay,
let's not get crazy time.
I've never been a big comedy short guy.
Uh,
I just recently,
like this year,
I've done like three sets there.
And,
uh,
that,
that's,
uh,
well,
I,
I've enjoyed going there and hanging out.
Like I think the last time
I saw you was there a,
when I rented you a few
years ago and you know,
a good friends of mine play there.
Um,
but I always had a strange feeling about
the place in which I'm starting to get
over now,
uh,
because I've,
I've enjoyed playing there this year.
But,
uh,
I'm from,
the Orlando Florida area
and when I was 19 years old,
I won this contest,
the funniest person in
central Florida contest.
Not Funny Person in Florida,
funny person in central Florida,
which I think is hilarious.
Um,
there was a kid in south
Florida who was a real bad ass.
Um,
and the Grand Prize of this contest was
I got to go to fly to Los Angeles and do
a set at the comedy store.
And I'm 19 years old,
man.
I've been no comedy for two years.
La.
The college or Oh my God,
you'd have thought I
was doing Johnny Carson.
This is my break,
baby.
Cool la man.
And in retrospect,
it was an open mic night
and I only did five minutes,
but there was a very
famous comedian there.
Uh,
I won't mention the man's name.
and he acted like I was the funniest
comedian and ever seen in his life.
And then he invites,
he a big guy.
I'm not saying it was a Pauly shore.
No,
no.
Let's just for the record
state who was not Pauly shore?
Uh,
no,
let's go.
Let's,
let's,
uh,
leave some mystery.
Um,
anyway,
so,
so Amy not be a big guy.
He invites me to hang out with him and
then he asked me to take a drive with him
and Oh my God,
you know,
wouldn't want to take a
drive with famous guy.
And,
uh,
we'd car car.
We parked in front of,
uh,
the rage on Santa Monica
for like 20 minutes,
and he said he's gay bar.
Well,
years later when I lived in La,
I find out the rage is like the
biggest gay bar in Los Angeles.
I had no idea at the time.
So this guy is showing
off his young meat and uh,
and then he says he needs to go
by his apartment in Beverly Hills.
And uh,
we go in and the,
on his wall,
he had all these photos of him and
famous people that were signed in.
And so we go from one side down
all the way and he's showing me,
you know,
this is me with Gandhi and
Martin Luther King and whatever,
whoever,
and a,
and then we get to the end of
the wall and it's the corner.
This was the guys move
to show you the pictures.
You start at one side and then boom,
you're in the corner.
And He makes this move on me.
And I'm 19 years old and
the guy steps in on me
and I just like,
I just like Kinda of I the n
and the guy steps in on me.
Any,
he cupped my ass.
Oh,
with each hand he's got it.
And it has to,
why you're afraid to say this man's name?
I don't say it.
Don't,
don't,
I won't say I won't.
I promise you,
I won't say it,
but I will say what it rhymes with.
No,
no,
no.
Don't,
don't,
don't do it.
Please don't.
Well,
I'm so anyway,
uh,
you know,
I said,
can we go back to the comedy store and,
um,
I can't help but reflect on that moment
all these years later and think how much
further my career would have gone
if I would've just fucked it up.
I don't think so.
You would lose all your street credit,
kidding Louis.
Anyway,
but that was why.
So like,
you know,
and I go back to Florida,
I'm 19 and like,
people are like,
hey,
how was your trip to Hollywood?
I don't want to talk about it.
And,
uh,
have you talked to him since [inaudible]
seven and never seen the guy ever
again.
But,
um,
uh,
but yeah,
so that kind of made me
chai away from the comedies.
Sure.
You ready to,
of course recording.
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?